five of them rolling oh sorry
why is candy crush so addictive
I mean there's a 97 million of us
playing this game every day candy crush
is the latest in a long line of games
that follow the maxim a minute to learn
a lifetime to master previous examples
include Angry Birds Tetris even twister
the idea here is that candy crush gives
players an immediate sense of
accomplishment but with 544 levels and a
new level being added about every two
weeks total mastery of the game is
elusive and it keeps people coming back
for more after you've used up all of
your lives
candy crush can prevent you from playing
again for up to 24 hours that lengthens
the game's appeal since you can't binge
on it and then get tired of it after a
week there are ways around these limits
but if you're seeking loopholes you're
probably already addicted most games
require both hands which means you can't
do anything else
candy crush lets you multitask you can
eat while you play you can talk on the
phone while you play you can go to
meetings and not pay attention while you
play all of this is white king digital
the makers of candy crush hope the
game's success will lead to bigger
prizes but the games industry is full of
one-hit wonders
something King hopes to avoid with newer
titles that are in the works
after all he can't live on candy forever
you